before we even started the design
process I showed Sue some diagrams one
was built into the hillside but it was
contrasted with a second option which
was the more of a treehouse version Sue
knew exactly what she wanted
the way I survived the first weeks after
my husband's death was to be up in the
Trees of Great Falls so when I was ready
to move out of the house where Mike died
what I immediately looked for was a lot
that was full of trees right so I could
get that feeling that feeling of being
in nature which was so critical to my
healing in those early days
the first thing we did is to look
carefully at the site at the various
experiences that were possible and that
meant thinking three-dimensionally not
just about the ground plane not just
about where you're walking on the ground
but what's up in the air
welcome to my tree house this place is
my Haven my Oasis and my work of art
[Music]
The Experience walking into my home
starts whenever you walk across a
floating walkway that bridge like entry
is the first kind of moment of leaving
the land and you're also seeing the
nature you know sort of below that
almost like you're on a boardwalk in a
nature preserve
this is my great room one of the
beauties of this room is you can see
front to back and side to side the trees
everywhere and also have this beautiful
fireplace and my poet's corner all
combined into this room
what I love about this corner is that
you can take a look at the entire view
shed so that's a term that Robert my
architect taught me where you're taking
a look at the open space ahead of you
she was very very clear about what she
wanted but she never said what style and
to me that is actually the essence of
modern it's not about style it's about
addressing the actual needs that you
have and that's a form of freedom and
that's a form of liberation
this is my screen porch and this is a
room that I spend so much time in all
weekend long these screens are Next
Level they're floor to ceiling with only
a bifurcation in the middle for safety
purposes they let you feel like you're
outside so this room is a very much of a
draw for when people come over they want
to spend time on the screen porch I
think on the screen porch more so than
anywhere else in the house you feel in
the trees you don't have that layer of
glass it is a little bit dangerous
because you're up so high but you're
safe that's by Design
foreign
here we are in the kitchen so the most
beautiful feature of this kitchen are
these windows these are spectacular the
way that they wrap around and you can
get a view of all the different kinds of
trees outside and then on a personal
note one of the parts of the kitchen
that I love the most is the sink so Mike
and I my husband at a prior house had a
beautiful sink this kalista sink and so
whenever we were designing this kitchen
I wanted to incorporate a little piece
of the past into the present and the
future because we wanted to take
advantage of that view there are no
upper cabinets in this kitchen so we had
to think about how to make it functional
and we solved that by creating a wall of
vertical cabinets that have the
refrigerator and the pantries
basically all the storage in one element
that's very convenient to the island
my true favorite room in my house is my
office one of the biggest ways that I
healed after the loss of my husband was
reading right out of the gate I read the
classic a year of magical Thinking by
Joan Didion and many others that told
stories about grief and loss so
sometimes when I'm on a work call I'll
just climb up on my couch and pull out a
book that I think is appropriate for the
person I'm talking to on a call I'll
remember something an Insight that I
gained from one and I want to pull it
out for someone oh my gosh Dave Grohl
the most hilarious awesome book but full
of life lessons because people think
that nobody talks about loss but every
single Memoir I have here has an example
of how someone has gotten through loss
for Dave Grohl that was his Nirvana
experience
[Music]
here on the master bedroom level you get
to see the canopy so that's why I refer
to this floor as my bird's nest I'm a
bird tucked in the very top of the trees
of course we get to have the feeling of
a floor-to-ceiling window consuming the
entire room but when you look at it in
reality there is a space on either side
so that space is designed to make the
windows more economical to the window
company can make them more in their
normal thresholds rather than it being
completely custom there's a benefit the
cost benefit that we always look at so
that extra inch is it really worth you
know five thousand dollars you know
probably not and then also you'll notice
there are no shades on these windows I'm
so high up no one's seeing into them and
in addition it just makes me feel like
I'm more in nature I'm an early riser so
I get up with the sun sometimes from my
bed I watch the sun rise Through the
Windows and watch all the colors of the
sky and that's the way I like it
came to designing this space here in the
master bath
I had lived 18 years of marriage with
double sinks so I kept telling Robert
and Ben well no we'll put two sinks in
here and they kept looking at me very
nicely and very kindly and didn't kind
of want to point out that I was just a
single person and what would I need a
double sink for so we had to come to
Jesus moment where we were staring at
the plans at their New York office and I
finally had to really absorb the fact
that I was a single person and a single
sink would be great
[Music]
is this style of architecture what Mike
Diegel would have wanted no but that's
kind of the beauty of it I get to
express myself in it while knowing that
whatever it would take for us to heal
and move forward whatever it would take
to support our lives he would support
one really precious precious thing to me
is this letter that my husband wrote me
10 years almost before he died
sweetheart I was just thinking about how
much I missed you
sometimes when I fly I think about what
would happen if I passed away and you
Connor and Kendall were without me I
wonder will they be okay
have I done all I can so that they will
be if indeed something should happen
know that all I would want for you all
is to move forward with your lives
living them fully and happily your
devoted husband Michael
oh